but let's let's talk about the story
that's going to get us in trouble
here we go exclusive from the daily mail
they say covet 19 at quote has no
credible natural ancestor and was
created by chinese scientists who then
tried to cover their tracks with quote
retro engineering to make it seem like
it naturally arose from bats explosive
new study claims
they say
these the study
researchers found unique fingerprints in
coven 19 samples they say could only
have arisen from manipulation and
laboratory now i will stress
we've already heard this last year and
you had that one guy luke what's his i
can't remember his name he's a famous
virologist won the nobel peace prize
said the same thing they called him a
crackpot they called him a conspiracy
theorist we've heard similar things
before we're hearing it again and the
weirdest thing right now is a bunch of
journalists that are like there's no
evidence lab leak is real there's all
the evidence that it was natural
zoologic you know transfer or whatever
and i'm like all right let me let me
break down all y'all for where for uh
let me let me break down where we're at
so far
okay i'm going to start with the
timeline as we know it now not what's
the timeline of the reporting
u.s provided funding to ecohealth
alliance money from that fund from that
pool went to the wuhan lab for what's
called gain of function research where
they tried to
make viruses gain functions
the idea is that by making a virus
stronger will understand it before it
emerges in the wild
so that's happening
then around november 2019 some people
got sick videos came out reports came
out suggesting that at some point people
had been bitten by a bat or bats had
peed on somebody so then a few months
later we start getting reports of this
sickness emerging in wuhan
it starts spreading and then we start
getting speculation that it's from the
wet market across the street
from the wuhan lab
already people are asking questions
could it have emerged and you know i i
said often you know look
it's a background a virus
people in a wet market are it's
unsanitary actually i would i would
argue that makes more sense simply
because
a bio lab still has security but market
doesn't so if i'd if i'd if you told me
to put a hundred bucks then i'd be like
the place with no security why would i
better the place with security but then
when you factor in the fact that they
were doing gain of function research on
bat coronaviruses when you when you
factor in that people were getting sick
everything starts to line up now we got
fauci himself saying he's not convinced
it occurred naturally and then we get
the story they go on to say
daily mail exclusively obtained a 22
page paper authored by the british
professor angus
dalgleich
and norwegian scientist dr berger
sorensen set to be published in the
quarterly review of biophysics discovery
the studies show that there's evidence
to suggest chinese scientists created
the virus while working on a gain of
function project at the wuhan lab gain
of function research which was
temporarily outlawed in the us involves
altering naturally occurring viruses to
make them more infectious in order to
study their potential effects on humans
according to the paper chinese
scientists took a natural chronovirus
backbone found in chinese cave bats and
spliced onto it a new spike
turning it into the deadly and highly
transmissible covid19 the researchers
who concluded that cova 19 has no
credible natural ancestor also believe
scientists reverse engineered versions
of the virus to cover up their tracks
quote we think that there have been
retro-engineered viruses created dal
glacier told dailymail.com they've
changed the virus then tried to make out
it was a sequence years ago the study
also points to deliberate destruction
concealment or contamination of data in
chinese labs and notes that scientists
who wish to share their findings haven't
been able to do so or have disappeared
now that's where it gets a little weird
that i'd like to read about that because
it sounded conspiratorial
until recently most experts have
staunchly denied the origins of the
virus were anything other than naturally
uh natural infection leaping from
animals to human earlier this week dr
anthony fauci defended u.s funding of
the wuhan institute of virology saying
the six hundred thousand dollar grant
was not approved for gain of function
research and i also want to make sure we
absolutely stress
fouchy bombshell as reported by the
hill.com not convinced covet 19
developed naturally outside wuhan lab
take just take that quote from fauci all
right we're gonna we're gonna we're
gonna sit here we're gonna say i don't
know about this study maybe the study is
not true i don't know all right
youtube's banned people for less
but fauci said he's not convinced it
developed naturally outside the lab
if the first reported cases were from
outside the lab but it didn't develop
naturally outside the lab then it stands
to reason the lab leak hypothesis is
true and it was manufactured in the lab
or unless vouchers wrong again it
developed naturally in the lab
how does it develop naturally in lab i
don't know
like the logic follows
a possibility the moment they put the
virus in the lab let's say let's say
they found the virus in a bat and they
put the bat in the lab
and they put the bat in a in a box
and then the virus mutates that's that's
that's lab engineered they change the
conditions of the bat that's the bare
minimum for me i suppose look this is a
tremendous
horrible horrible slander of the wet
market community
i mean it is
and i mean imagine the guy who owns that
wet market
is it one man is it one guy i don't know
maybe he's the one guy who subleases to
all the others there's wet marketeers
did you see that new york times reporter
who said that lab leak was racist
sure yeah of course well no i mean
what's more racist lab league or wet
market exactly
so it's it's that that's what's funny
it's so uh the reporter for the new york
times who's covering covet tweeted that
one day we'll we'll stop talking about
lab leak and discuss the racist origins
or whatever and then people were like
the wet market is more
racist you know like the lab is
plausible in that people labs have
accidents could happen but then to
accuse the chinese people of having
these filthy disease-ridden markets well
it's because we eat bats
i mean
yeah but did they really i thought that
was like an urban legend
or like a myth that they were eating
bats like people were saying bat soup
and then i guess what are you selling
what are you selling live bats for at a
wet market
i don't know i mean this is all this is
all you know coming from
media reports and you know all that all
that nonsense that uh that came out in
initially you know we heard about the
wet market we heard about the bats and
were you know people joking about bat
soup and all this stuff and and of
course then the media backlash oh my god
all this is racist yeah so so don't talk
about it it's all racist
it's it's the weirdest thing uh and i
guess it's because they hated trump and
trump suggested it so then all of a
sudden they had to i think it's a
combination of of that trump says
something they must say the opposite but
i also i also think that politically
they saw it as a way to go after trump
if this was a natural phenomenon it's
trump's fault and then they can they can
they can use that to get trump out think
about this though
we we haven't we have an idea that the
media is getting less powerful as
alternative media
rises
i i thought that for a couple of years i
thought that it was declining in power
and what
kovitz showed me was that these guys are
still
insanely powerful i mean think about
this we have
the biggest story in the world everyone
is
hysterical afraid of this virus
and yet
we're like a year on and we're only now
starting to think hey where had this
thing happened
i mean right
in what world is that you know 9 11
happens immediately as soon as as the
rubble is is cleared no not even not
even
you know the the the i was in new york
the uh the sky is full of clouds it's
like all right who did it right
how'd this happen who did it
and for this we we go a year and and and
it's not just the media though clearly
the media is a component of an
establishment power
that's
they they either because they are
pressured by each other they're scared
of of being ostracized
cnn says something youtube says that's
the truth we decided we if cnn says it
it's true and so you go on youtube and
you make some claims at the election
they'll ban you you make some claims
about cove they'll ban you but for four
years
the media could go on youtube and make
the most outrageous nonsensical claims
about donald trump and it was totally
acceptable sure so yeah i i you know
i'll tell you this
i've made the point that uh
social media has empowered the
individual
but like i stated in in the opening when
i was doing the promo spot cnn gets
hundreds of millions of views on youtube
why because youtube guarantees that if
you search for news they will send you
cnn it's not just that they've decided
cnn is the truth they've decided it's
the only thing you're allowed to watch
so how do we combat that
people just got to keep talking talk as
much as you can i guess and it's even
worse than that because you've got an
entire industry now that has developed
the you know the let's say the so-called
disinformation industry which is really
just a mutation of the old countering
violent extremism
um industry during the uh the the war on
terror it's basically the same people
oh yeah they've retooled themselves and
they've created
metrics
and all kinds of justifications for
saying no cnn is authoritative but tim
poole isn't is you know disinformation
well so they actually google told me i
could become authoritative if i chose to
do it if there's a process you go
through you have to like fill out forms
and then submit something and then they
put you in their authoritative list so
it's possible uh the the challenge is
that
it's it's an obvious institutional bias
so
i do believe
youtube likes me more than other
channels
i do because you get a lot of views
maybe uh
but i i certainly think that
you know there are smaller channels that
are still decently sized that have
gotten strikes for saying similar things
to me
and you know we're running a risk here
simply talking about the story because
youtube they go nuts i mean crowder
cited the cdc data and they nuked him
right so well i mean i also think that
you've got such you've created such a
nice
serious infrastructure around the show
with you know with the house and the
equipment and the team and everything i
mean
that
i think that
for youtube and some of these you know
let's just say for youtube they look at
this and they say this is this is a
story that we want told right right we
want someone like tim poole to be able
to make a living and to thrive on this
platform yeah it's not a because if you
if you get you know
you get yanked and you get banned
that's a big story right and it's been
it's bad for business it's bad for me
youtube is a very dangerous place to run
a business facebook is a very dangerous
place to run a business and if so
actually youtube did a survey they said
they sent me this uh everybody got it
probably a youtuber and it's like fill
out our survey and it asks me questions
about what platforms i use and
i'm like i use you know twitter
instagram tic tac whatever
and then it's like how do you feel about
them how confident are you and i'm just
like oh not at all like twitter like do
you feel safe using enough no way do you
think they have your best interest and
absolutely not and then for youtube i'm
like youtube is definitely not a safe
place for a business
it does provide an opportunity for reach
and for for revenue
but youtube could ban you at any moment
without notice and they've done it
before
they did it to a guy named monkey jones
he had no strikes he broke no rules and
they deleted all of his channels without
warning because they were they found his
content distasteful that was it he broke
no rules he just made it it was it was
black comedy
and they didn't like it he did he uh
i'll leave it there it's it's spicy
comedy but it wasn't racist it was just
it was like the edge of edgy and they
deleted his channel outright so this is
this is the world we live in right now
where of course youtube wants people to
believe you can be a creator so long as
you follow these rigid guidelines we
don't explain to you i mean we will
change at any moment right we just
learned this is really interesting from
project veritas too
i don't know if you saw this where they
had the whistleblower come out and they
say that publicly facebook's guidelines
are very vague
internally they're extremely well
defined
and they do that so that way when they
ban someone they can oh well you know
this rule is violated for this reason
and they can just make it whatever they
want right
so i mean twitter is the same
twitter operates exactly the same way
that i i was a few years ago
i was in a uh back and forth at length
with some twitter folks you know
folks who work at the company whose job
it was they saw hey you know what let's
reach out to conservatives who are you
know who have a
a platform on online and uh
and i went at them and i said look
you're
um you're shadow banning you're doing
all these things you're throttling the
amount of views that people will get
that that viewers will get
and they denied all of this
but they admitted to having i think some
300 different metrics
or types of metrics that will decide
who you are based on behaviors right so
that they can look you in the eye and
they say we do not
ban conservatives
there it is it is the stupidest lie
and the issue i guess is
i don't i don't know
why any conservative would believe them
and i don't know why any conservative
would argue them i've argued with them
but we know they're lying they know we
know they're lying
and they know we know they know they're
lying they they know we know
they know we know they're lying yes yeah
i wrote a piece about it at uh
at uh the federalist
i think in 20 2018
describing this whole back and forth
and uh and i told them you know
my twitter hasn't grown
more than i don't know
200 300 in the last nine months
it's obvious that something is going on
because because of how you know
exponential growth works right and the
guy looked at me and said
maybe your tweets just aren't so good
we can offer you a class on how to tweet
better wow yeah i mean
yeah
you know and this guy had like
you know 400 followers or something and
he that he's and he's and he's talking
to me and and it's like i mean
it's so obvious that the finger is on
the scale it's so obvious that that this
is going on it's not even debatable but
of course you've got you know we went
through four years of donald trump yeah
where i knew this was a problem in in
january of 2017. you know i mean i i'm
not special
a lot of people saw that this was an
issue
and nothing was done the republicans
didn't do anything about it when they
had the power to do it nothing and
they're not gonna know
we get hearing after hearing after
hearing they don't do anything oh at the
uh at the federal level absolutely not
at the federal level
all these guys so desantis so i was
there at the uh at the bill signing i
was there at the bill signing
and uh and it was great the room was
electric
because everybody knows what
is is up here everybody knows it used to
be that it's like okay you know milo
alex jones these people who
you know you'd never meet in a million
years but you know
they got banned
but now it's grandma getting banned
yeah it's people who are just saying you
know learn to code making jokes thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to see the
full show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time